thank you
[Music]
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the Daily
Mirror con this Susie Boniface and the
former BBC sports editor mihir Bose
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
well let's start with the eye which
leads with the walkout by BBC Sports
personalities after their colleague Gary
lineker was taken off air for tweeting
his opinions about the migrant crisis
the Murat has the simple Splash Revolt
for lineker
the theme of Revolt continues in the
telegraph
the mail has the headline Mutiny at BBC
over linica red card
the times has a similarly mutinous
splash
the guardian plays it straight down the
middle lineker suspended from BBC over
social media round
and the star attempts a pun Biebs gone
to VAR
meanwhile the express focuses on the
meeting today between Rishi sunak and
Emmanuel macron at which the two leaders
struck an agreement over how to handle
the situation in the channel
and the Ft leads with the collapse of
Silicon Valley Bank in the United States
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Susie Boniface and mihir Bose welcome to
both of you let's start with the
guardian on the story that all of the
papers I think by one have on their
front pages and this is the suspension
of Gary lineker from his BBC program
match of the day kick us off Susie no
pun intended actually then
it's an entirely confected row which is
neatly different defecting everybody
from actually looking at the policy that
Gary lineker was talking about the new
illegal immigration bill which Zoella
bravaman and Richie sunac are banking
the house on in terms of being able to
quote stop the boats with this new
legislation the fact that Gary lineker
expressed an opinion about that is more
of a story than actually the legislation
now it doesn't matter whether you are
um you know pro-refugee and think
everyone on those boats should be
welcomed and treated kindly or if you
are anti all those people on the boats
and you think they should all be
deported and sent back once they came
whichever side of that argument you're
on this is not going to help you the
legislation isn't going to do what it
says on the side of the tin it's
intended to fail and by having a row
with the BBC and about the BBC which the
BBC itself is managing to actually feed
because it's eating itself in this
horrific you know self-immolation
self-flagellation going oh no what would
be done wrong now
because they're actually helping the
Tory party do that they are neatly
deflecting all the attention that the
BBC and us and others should be giving
to this policy
um but having said that the nicest man
in football
um getting told off is actually more
interesting and entertaining To The
World At Large than an immigration
policy isn't it let's face it
um but the fact is that you know if Gary
lineker is or isn't fired by the BBC if
he is or isn't on the match of the day
tomorrow it makes no difference to those
people traffickers and to the people who
are risking their lives desperate to
flee to somewhere better it makes no
difference whatsoever to the fundamental
problems but let's talk about it for the
next day or two anyway
do you agree with Susie that uh this
story that the lineker story deflects
from um serious discussion about the
bill
yes it does of course that is that is
very clear you can see from the front
pages uh Rishi sunak has uh gone to
France uh Anton cordial and all that and
that's nowhere apart from the express
um on the front I agree with Susie that
Gary and lineage a very nice man I have
very fond memories of him uh he led my
club to its uh last FA Cup Triumph and
all that sort of thing it brings me
great memories but I must say with great
respect to Gary and and I as I said I
have a great deal of time for him as a
contrarian an MCC member who refuses to
wear a tie and therefore doesn't go into
the long room unlike me
um but you see the point is he also
hasn't played this very well I must say
he's absolutely should be entitled to
express his views but I think to put it
that the the government policy Compares
um to the what the Germans did in 1930s
was I think going over the top and then
afterwards he got into a sort of verbal
football match with the ministers as it
were you know
um the first the Home Secretary and then
Penny Morton and things like that which
I think given his position in the BBC he
should have been more careful about let
me not try and excuse the BBC how they
have handled it they've handled it very
badly and it again shows how beleaguered
the BBC is and how sensitive and I know
having worked at the BBC how sensitive
they were about any criticism
particularly if it came from the Daily
Mail and and there is of course a
tremendous pressure on the BBC the
feeling that the license fee may go the
the chairman is under pressure things
like that and you know it doesn't show
the BBC in very good life but having
said that I think Gary he was perfectly
entitled to criticize but it's a
question of how you criticize and I
think that is the question and how you
actually get embroiled into a complete
clash with ministers as if you were
representing some sort of
um group or some sort of party I think
that probably uh he didn't play with
great skill yeah you may mentioned that
the clash with ministers but but it was
Penny Morden who raised his name in the
Commons though wasn't it
I'm here
uh yes it she did yes and of course you
know uh I think her knowledge of
football uh shall we say is something
that that is uh that is best left to one
side one point where I make about this
is what is interesting is that some of
the comments being made in the papers
um comes over as if
um Sports people shouldn't have
political views this reminds me of my
early days in sports journalism when to
write on sport in a newspaper you felt
you were in the kindergarten that you
went to the back pages you know just
keep your your opinions on on on
football and cricket and you know what
Manchester United or Tottenham are doing
uh don't expect don't expect to have any
any any views on on wider issues there's
a bit of that you know calling Gary
lineker sanctimonious footballer turned
pundit and so on there's a bit of that
uh if you like a snobbery and and the
artist looking down on the heart is
Susie is Gary lineker entitled to have
his uh political views and and share
them on Twitter
in the same way that the director
general of the BBC is entitled to have
once stood to be a conservative
counselor in in Hammersmith and Fulham
um the fact is that I think there's
there's a couple of things at work here
which is people not quite understanding
some stuff so the BBC as with sky has
rules with ofcom about how you need to
be impartial which is why you're you
know coming to and fro and asking the
balanced questions
um but it's news editorial staff the the
front of house people that do the news
have extra tough rules about them and
how impartial they have to be someone
like Gary lineker who is in sport
doesn't have quite the same tough rules
he does have more leeway to say stuff
and as a freelancer whatever he is or
isn't allowed to say on air is going to
come down to his contract which only he
and his agent and the BBC are going to
know about we're not going to know about
what's in there and dare say it does not
say at any point that he's not allowed
to tweet and he's got a perfect right I
think to question it when you consider
the fact that
um at the start of the World Cup in
Qatar for example you know uh The Daily
Mail British sized
um lineker and the BBC for talking about
human rights they criticized him for
talking about having a World Cup Opening
Ceremony where they weren't
concentrating the ceremony and they're
actually talking about the human rights
abuses in Qatar instead and this is a
copy of the daily mail from November a
page where they criticized
um Gary lineker for talking about taking
some money from Al Jazeera over the
years and how dare he take money from
Qatar their human rights abusers now if
that's the case the male's gonna be
right to report this but they brought
minica's got every right as well to talk
about any human rights abuses he thinks
are happening down the road it doesn't
matter it's Qatar or the UK you have
that right to express that opinion and I
think I can understand how some people I
know at the BBC and Mahia will know as
well are Furious that they are not
allowed to say stuff and follow these
rules really closely and that lineaka
makes their job more difficult when he
speaks out like this but
um you know if Jeremy Clarkson is
allowed to work on Top Gear when he was
a sun columnist if Andrew Andrew Neil
was allowed to run a police politics
show when he's been a columnist and to
run The Spectator magazine when Richard
Sharp is allowed to be the chairman of
the BBC you haven't given massive
massive helped fixed massive loans for
the Prime Minister then I really don't
think there's an awful lot to to
criticize them for and one other tiny
thing there's been a lot of
um
misunderstanding of what happened in
Germany in the 1930s so when Gary said
that this is reminiscent of the
conversations that were had in Germany
1930s and here so that was a bit too
strong I think some people when they
hear that think that that means a direct
reference to the Holocaust now that
happened 10 years later that was the
1940s and what happened in the 1930s was
an awful lot of rhetoric about how
migrants and other communities and
Jewish communities were causing a
problem and we couldn't afford it and it
wasn't sustainable and they had to be
booted out now that was happening in
Germany in the 1930s lineker's right to
draw a parallel to that he was incorrect
and that that kind of conversation and
that kind of rhetoric was also happening
in British politics at the time it was
happening in American politics it was
happening all around the world at
different points but you know in the
1930s was not a nice time to be alive
for a lot of people and I think Clinica
was right to draw that parallel let's
just bring uh back in on
um those points and and the fact that
the story has um developed further in
what's really blown it up this evening
is the solidarity starts taken by many
of uh Gary lineker's colleagues refusing
to appear or present match of the day
Maria
yes can I make one point to Susie I
think it's a question of how you express
it and you've got to realize that Gary
lineker with 8.9 million Twitter
followers is himself a huge broadcaster
bigger broadcaster and I know um that we
are being watched by about 20 million
viewers tonight but I think you know
um or maybe even more who knows but you
know but Gary lineker is red and reacted
to by by a lot of people so in a way he
has a huge platform but I think what
what this what what people are calling a
Revolt a mutiny whatever word you want
to use what this shows is that we have
now a new breed of footballers let's
let's you know I mean the public needs
to get used to that there was this breed
of footballers not all that long ago who
didn't bother about wider society when
there was for instance their fellow
black players were being victimized and
and racially abused and that didn't say
anything but now those players are not
like that they have moved on on they're
aware of the world and they're willing
to express their views and I think the
BBC and and the program they're going to
present tomorrow will not have any any
presenters any any analysts and so on
they will find that if they don't sort
this problem out with Gary lineker a lot
of the commentators that have will also
be in revolt against what they're doing
and and this will be a major problem
because this is not the the the uh the
mild Meek footballer who might be
ferocious on the on on the field of play
but once he's off the off the field of
play he's he's uh is is is and got his
cap on and and Bows to whoever the
chairman or the manager is that we're
living in a different world and and the
revolt and the reaction to what has
happened to Gary lineker shows that and
Susie do you think this is only the
beginning of the the problems for the
BBC because they've sorted out
tomorrow's program there will be no
presenters there will be no uh pundits
it would sort of be a highlight show
will remains be seen what they exactly
will broadcast but what happens the week
after and the week after that
I'm hoping for return of teletext let's
just hand that back it was fine
um no I think one of the things that
that the BBC has mishandled this so
badly and they they do this because they
they spend so much time worrying if
they're getting it right which is what
they're supposed to do that they
actually sometimes overdo it too much
all they had to do when this round blew
up was to say hang on the government I
thought you were all for free speech
and that would have shut everything down
Gary lineker is allowed to have uh his
opinions he's allowed to say them it
doesn't affect his job it doesn't affect
the rest of the BBC the fact that
someone in the Tory party wanted to
criticize him for it and that's then
been allowed to be Amplified and shouted
about is is the thought the BBC is
sticking on the top of the 10 o'clock
news frankly if they hadn't done that it
wouldn't be a big issue but he's he's
got a right to freedom of speech and the
party who's in government at the moment
is so big on freedom of speech it's one
of their big you know if you do a little
Venn diagram the things they love it's
it's uh getting rid of the migrants and
freedom of speech that kind of all
collapses all together and then this one
has caused them a huge headache um but
frankly if you took you know Gary lunica
away from this yes it was me here is
right he's got nearly nine million
followers on Twitter how many people
would have seen that initial tweet out
of those nine million not an awful lot
of them because that's not how the
algorithm Works you're not on Twitter
all the time every time it wouldn't have
made any difference at all what stories
have done by shouting about this and the
BBC has helped them by making it into a
big confected row is that there are
millions of people worldwide who don't
follow Gary lineker my mum your mums
everybody's mums now knows about what he
thinks on the small boats crisis and
he's talking about what happened in
1930s Germany and saying well was he
right or was he not right and the Tories
have kind of just you know everyone is
now talking about whether or not they
are Nazis